hey guys welcome to skyj this is my
sister jenna hi so let's now ask
both of us
okay that's good great so for this
episode i decided to take my questions
from instagram jenna also is going to be
doing one on her channel so check it out
after this our first question is
chandler guerrero wants some advice for
going into high school uh
i've been in high school in like five
years i graduated i graduated high
school five years ago do you know when i
graduated don't even want to i don't
even think about it don't do the math
because i just did it
how old was i
oh
my god oh my god this has been helping
him go into high school um
forget your locker combination maybe
play some sports join some clubs yeah
make sure your community service yep
anyway next question that's long do you
know tom hiddlestorm you should because
he was at san diego comic con so we're
150 1999
other people
do you know him no
i i don't know should we look him up go
on to the next question no i want to
know who thomas is this tom the avengers
thor oh i did see him we had coffee
[Music]
did we know no
i wish tell thomas
tom hiddleston wife oh she's cute i like
her shoes okay no we didn't hang out
with tom what do you think about justin
bieber peeing in a mop bucket i didn't
see the video did you yeah you saw i was
like he was in some back kitchen and he
just like peed in a bucket why because
it was right yeah i think he said
something about bill clinton
what level are you guys in candy crush
140 can't get past 140 been stuck on it
for two and a half weeks let me see what
i'm on 50.
you're real far yeah i don't have a life
how did i make my costume for comic-con
real simple
someone else made it
dan dan wants to know do you even lift
um
[Music]
kate marie wants to know if
we like to sing
oh lately i've been laughing losing
sleep i keep forgetting the worst it's
okay we've listened to it over 100 times
what's your favorite type of fruit oh oh
raspberries oh i was thinking of animal
crossing fruit well real life probably
bananas and coconuts since they're the
tropical when you get more money for
those bananas make me so sick did you do
stupid things in high school i don't
want to talk about high school anymore
done what do you consider your personal
style to be jenna sweatpants comfortable
you're wearing them right now
[Music]
nice top sweatpants i'm just wearing
black pants i consider my personal style
to be awesome
or oh camo military oh yeah
did you run on your last video
no i took it off if you had to listen to
one album for the rest of your life what
would it be
[Music]
[Applause]
what would you do if real life was like
animal crossing i would have a lot of
money because i work every day to get
those bells while i'm sitting on the
couch in real life making no money
yeah
true story i'd also be really fit
because i run so fast all of my grass is
dead mine do ugh
i don't have any more questions i have
some if you want to go over to me johnny
you can
see the questions that i haven't read
yet
i'll see you guys later thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe be
sure to check out jen's channel and make
sure you
check out my channel again
no no no no
no i said no no no did you show them the
mustache kitty oh my god guys this cat
has a mustache hold on a minute
oh my god hamilton hamilton
beautiful okay bye my best bud i wish